what up guys welcome to the just Harley
things YouTube channel today I am going
to be reacting to uh whatever podcast
clip but before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell like the video on your
way in let's get started roll the tape
33. why would you be dating a 19 year
old what's wrong with oh oh wow this is
very loud what what what's wrong with
that I mean you're what do you have in
common with a 19 year old that just
graduated high school what what do I
have common with a 33 year old
litigation attorney I don't know I don't
maybe you guys could talk about movies
in the 80s or something but like but I
feel like 19 she's not she's old enough
she says for her you to take her to a
bar though okay
I mean unless it's an event or something
well so I don't go to bars or clubs I'd
rather masturbate with sandpaper than go
something
let me address the age thing then I'll
have to address the body count thing so
um this is another one that always comes
up men are always shamed for their
preferences men's preferences are always
almost almost always met with contempt
derision shaming yeah and that's totally
true look it why isn't she shamed for
dating an older guy like why is he
shamed for dating the younger guy like I
think it's one thing if he's like a big
player you know and whatever that's like
a different story but it's like if she
wants to date him and she's over the
legal age of consent and he wants to
date her what is the issue and then the
other issue you get in is like you'll
have girls saying they were groomed at
like 21 22 like 23 years old even 19
like that's old enough to know what
you're doing so my issue is when these
two people date they put all of the onus
of responsibility on him like oh he's
the bad guy if he wants to date a
younger woman but there are shows called
like cougar Island where 40 year old
women date 20-something-year-old then no
one cares about that in one
nobody shames women
but um so just to make something clear
most the women like I've dated yeah and
is it predatory if it's super beautiful
woman goes after an ugly rich guy is
that predatory you know because she's
abusing her looks and Beauty a couple
years I tear up between the age of 25
and 34. in fact I did a 45 year old uh
no younger than 25.
um I might have gone on a date with a
girl who's 21 at one point but mostly
I'm dating around my age like 20 mid to
late 20s to early 30s will you girls
what what is your perspective on like
age gaps what do you what do you guys
think because I feel like a lot of women
they prefer like guys that are older
right I think it depends I I prefer guys
that are older I don't think there's
anything wrong with that well let me
look and it also depends on the type of
guy like if he's a good dude and he's 33
and he wants to marry you and start a
family with you like what's wrong with
that if they want the same things not so
do you guys think that guys your age are
immature our age our your age you think
they're immature for the most part yeah
yeah so how can you simultaneously hold
that position
but also shame me for wanting to date
someone younger if you want to date I
assume you're more attracted to men who
are older because they're more mature
maybe they're more attractive maybe they
have their [__] together maybe they're
more willing to commit to you whereas
these I mean I don't want to speak for
all the men who are younger but
they're for the street streets I'm
kidding I'm kidding guys
what if you
what if you already fell in love with
the girl and like we're in a committed
relationship and she lied about it and
then you found out later would you break
up with her also at what point are you
asking her what's your body count at
what point am I asking the first date
and you're like no I'm usually not overt
I'm I'm not overt about that sort of
questioning so I wouldn't be like how
many men have you slept with I'm I mean
it could somehow come up organically for
you know on the topic of that but I mean
I'd honestly try to suss it out in other
ways I'd probably ask like have you ever
ever done any swinging I think
threesomes can kind of be a good
indicator more than threesome's
foursomes can kind of be an indicator of
promiscuity I feel like a lot of people
would lie about that yeah the other
thing is yeah and that's the thing like
guys will never actually know you know
girls can lie but the thing is if you've
done enough guys can smell it on you
they're not stupid and you know some
girls do get away with it but it's like
how long how long can they really get
away with it before you know parts of
your past come back to bite you in the
ass you know especially nowadays
everyone's got a smartphone [__] gets
around be careful if you
if you are overtly asking
there's no guarantee that they're going
to tell you the truth so I mean age can
kind of be an indicator like you know if
they're a bit older I mean you can start
making some assumptions
um that's not a guarantee though I think
you can there's there's like some ways
you can kind of suss it out you can ask
her about her relationship history has
she had just
no long-term relationships and she's 30
she's probably for the streets not gonna
lie no offense but if you're 30 and you
haven't had any any long-term
relationships but you've been casually
dating bro that's got to be above 100
probably a hundred I'm gonna say but if
she had what's that what if she has a
lot of hobbies what do you mean a lot of
hobbies like she keeps herself busy and
doesn't sleep around like that there's
outliers there's outliers sure but
that's the thing like women we always
look for exceptions to the rule and this
coming with a girl
sing I played
I play with the exception do most women
my age that I know really have hobbies
like that no their hobby is brunch and
Mimosas that's their hobby it's like how
are you going to determine that like an
outlier from somebody who's not it's
tough it's tough out here I mean there
there's certain kind of does she party a
lot does she go to bars a lot does she
drink a lot you know so these are kind
of other things to kind of suck yeah
because guys the way that men see it
it's like okay if you walk like a hoe
you look like a hoe and you smell like a
how are they supposed to know you're not
a hoe so if every weekend you're in the
bars and you're drinking and you're
going out and you're partying like is
that typically where people find
long-term fulfilling happy relationships
clubs bars now now are there exceptions
sure but a guy is just gonna assume if
that's the lifestyle you're living like
at some point you got drunk and did
something stupid at some point you made
a choice you probably regret like man
they're not they're not dumb guys well
so I know this is Santa Barbara is a
very uh pretty much everyone here is an
alcoholic so not at the panel but
people [__] drink heavy as [__] in
Santa Barbara everyone's at you know so
especially at UCSB sbcc very heavy party
schools so I'm probably not making any
fans by saying I'm not a big drinker I
don't I don't party I don't go to bars I
don't go to clubs but um
yeah I think uh someone who's
if they frequently partake you know I
will say the bigger I get on YouTube the
more happy I am that really drinking has
not been a big part of my 20s
um yeah just just you know like happier
every day I made that choice life it can
be an indicator that they're a bit more
promiscuous it's not a guarantee but if
you're getting [__] tanked three
nights a week I can start making some
assumptions I could be wrong but uh but
he's not gonna take the time to find out
like guys guys don't have time to be FBI
investigators to figure out how many
guys you slept with like what exactly
you did if your lifestyle looks a
certain way they're gonna assume you are
a certain way so yeah there's there's
definitely some ways to tell you're
giving me the death stare over there
Jesus put on her I'm just listening and
analyzing but uh so okay I addressed
body count a little bit but as far as
the age goes
um I mean so you would take Coral with
like a 30 year old dating a 20 year old
I mean I feel like it depends on the
situation if some miraculously they were
to have a lot in common and
there is some depth to the relationship
I guess it wouldn't be a big deal
um do men really care if you I feel like
that's a female point of view like I
feel like women want to have stuff in
common with the guys but like the things
that men typically want from women is
like cooking you know motherly Instinct
like stuff that like really I guess it's
a bonus but can do you guys care do you
care that much no he's shaking his head
like I feel like that's like a woman's
point of view like mine don't really
care I don't know I feel like there's a
fine line between where it's predatory
and where it's not so it's it's hard to
say there's
and it this is the thing it's only
predatory based on how she feels if she
feels like it was predatory then it was
predatory so if the relationship doesn't
work out and I've had girls on my show
they're in a relationship with a guy
with two three years and then suddenly
it's predatory a lot of things that it
depends on I mean I reject I reject that
entirely any this idea of it being
predatory I absolutely can I add
something to it reject it
um I think I agree with her that it
depends but I think it depends on the
power play if somebody is a 20 year old
girl let's say very
foreign
ER has her things together let's talk
about celebrities Kylie Jenner her
boyfriend five six years older than her
I think in that situation is not as
predatory because they have a lot in
common she has her career together wait
so you're saying wasn't she underage oh
female logic just does not make sense so
a girl underage not predatory over okay
the the power that she has from being
this business Mogul a five to six year
age Gap is predatory how old is she how
old is Kylie well yes compare that
too-year-old man going to a college
party picking up a college girl who
doesn't have a lot of money don't
recommend that and doesn't have anything
in common with [__] Del Playa trying
to I'm not saying you no no I'm not
trolling here I'm not I didn't say it
was you but I'm just saying in general
it's different because in that case it
seems like he's just looking for a girl
who's you know younger doesn't have
money he can manipulate he can get you
know all those things but again I think
it depends on the circumstances
and what they have in common so
like if you would date a YouTuber that's
maybe 21 and you know you'll have a lot
in common I wouldn't think that's creepy
but again if you date a college girl
who's 19. so you think if if I were to
date a 19 year old college girl that
would be creepy personally yes okay
why why is it articulate why
well it's just imagine
let me ask you let me I want you can
answer that but is the reverse also
creepy so there's this concept of
cougars so absolutely so you think
so is the reverse do you take quarrel
with the reverse with the this if you
want to put it the exact same ages
again are you gonna shame cougars I
think are you cougar shaming how dare
you how dare you cougar shame I'm
standing up for the cougars cougars go
after those college boys get them again
I think it depends on the stage of Life
they're in if you're somebody who's in
their 30s a woman with a full-time
career a job why are you dating a boy
that has to do homework till 10 pm you
know or has to go to the library to
study for his finals it's kind of a
little weird you know but again if it's
a 20 year old who has this job you know
is a can we just make it an age thing
like why are we inputting all these
factors would that stand up in the court
of law was he of age or not of age was
she of age or not of age it's like as
women we go through all of these
loopholes to just like make things make
sense that don't make any sense now it's
like based on what job he has huh
there's nothing wrong with that just
depends on what stages of Life they're
in well I mean first off I would say
heaven forbid a man find a woman who is
at her Peak Physical attractive it's
attractive
um
so and I think I was more physically
attractive when I was younger so
um there's that uh I mean there's also
when you're younger you've had fewer
sexual partners and we just talked about
it I mean most men whether you like it
or not value sexual Purity in a woman
now don't get me wrong I know some 19
year old girls that have been [__]
run through they've hooked up with like
100 men and I'm not even exaggerating
Chris knows her
she's not not in the Chris doesn't know
her in the biblical sense but he knows
who I'm talking about and she's been
with 100 guys but it happens to be the
case that someone who's younger has had
fewer sexual partners men find that
attract an attractive quality in women
you know I I guys our life would be so
much easier if we just accepted reality
okay I could I could be mad I'm 26 I
could be mad maybe guys 26 would prefer
to date a girl 22 or you could just date
guys 10 to 15 years older you could just
play the game like why don't we just
play the game why do we have to be mad
like what the game is just play even
okay if you're a 40 year old woman okay
you could whine that the 40 year old men
are in India or you could date the
50-something-year-olds now you might
whine and be like oh well I don't want
the 50-something year olds well that's
the game I don't know what to tell you
it's like we think that whining about
the rules is gonna change them it just
is what it is take it take it for what
it is really that's a big reason why
like you know you see older guys you
know there's a certain point where the
girl starts getting older that you know
she gets hit on a lot less by you know
why guys because I feel like they're the
focus on younger the focus is on younger
girls I feel like I mean I noticed this
when I was a freaking in college
like it was like the Freshman would come
in and all the guys were like this is
like fresh meat I mean you know now
it just is what it is it just is what it
is it's like
so they want to find you know someone
who's not who's less promiscuous yeah
okay
um I really question why again as women
guys we just need to accept reality for
what it is it is what it is uh men
prefer younger women because they have
fertility and youth and historically
um you know men would prefer women that
were virgins because then they would
know that the kid was theirs and not
someone else's and we could argue with
reality all day or we could just accept
it and I think that we should move more
towards accepting reality so let me know
what you guys think like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
and I'll talk to you next time